the Joe Rogan experience a little high
but I am dying to hear the next door
neighbor events Epstein I can't stop
thinking after the show all right like
these stairs he theory so much no man
but you don't get into him someone asked
me why someone asked me why I was a
conspiracy theorist it was an interview
in there ask him some jujitsu interview
why are you conspiracy theorists and I
said why isn't everybody a goddamn
conspiracy theorist we all know the
government lies real life in it and then
you believe official stories doesn't
make any sense you'll like this so that
is my logic this venture capitalists
billionaires and she goes um see what
you know there's these ideas that you
know that people all these billionaires
get together and then they they they
figured out the world this we're going
to do this here and they leave you know
that's right like the skulls okay why
that's complete [ __ ] like the idea
that the powerful get together so he
goes she goes I tried to schedule a
dinner with five billionaires five and
they the reason they're billionaires is
because they're super competitive and
they [ __ ] hate their other
competitors she was I couldn't get five
of them sit at the table because one did
it [ __ ] the other guy's ex-wife the
other guy was suing the other guy the
other guy was trying to tissues business
but - she's in the out scratch is a cure
you actually you go please no it's
because human being competitive and
gentlemen please stop for a second if
there was a [ __ ] lady who wanted to
make a lunch with us we wouldn't know
who could get she get all mutants really
oh she
that was the end of the Illuminati
filmed all these idiots dressing up like
druids and worshipping the owl god
Molech that's real dude I didn't really
do that just brush all the world because
nobody's that organized well maybe
they're not but did you ever see a
mangrove thing that is absolutely 100%
right no it's not so what Brian it's
people dressing up like wizards
let's saying substantial control [ __ ] is
gonna be burning in effigy in front of
an owl Burning Man
bro this is so different than Burning
Man it's the government it's people at
the highest levels of banks it's all
these different famous people there's a
bunch of crazy really rich influential
people that went to that Bohemian Grove
and dress up like druids and they
chanted things have you ever seen it yes
you are cuz you were talking about and I
didn't believe in what do you mean you
believe it Jon Ronson was there Jon
Ronson is a hundred percent credible
journalist yeah whatever you might think
about anybody else that was there
although the different people that have
made youtube videos on it Jon Ronson is
legit as they come straight down the
middle very intelligent to think they're
doing their are they I think there's
the same way they do the skullenbones
where they get together and they have a
group where they all become a part of
this group early on and they feel some
kinship just like the Freemasons just
like a lot of people but this is very
extreme well they're they're chanting
crazy [ __ ] are putting hoods on and
they're burning an effigy that's
supposed to be a sacrificial person but
it's straw and a bundle them do and then
they talk about the owl god Molech
okay these are multimillionaires you
know Marina Abramovic is of course he
doesn't now you do but Brian but your
initiative your initial reactions now
you like that no I don't believe that is
crazy no but I just don't believe that
that I don't believe all run the world
organized enough okay to actually get
together and create a cabal rich let me
give you a two-step here guys you
believe the footage from Bohemian Grove
that really was these heads of banks and
heads you believe that right and they're
all together right yeah so wouldn't they
talk about business yeah well that's
probably how they do it this is probably
what it's all about it's probably not as
you like to think it's their fight you
lazy horse their organ because you
become a team with all the other popular
like them they do things like influence
crew that's what they do you go why
don't you send a billion dollars look at
this this is a hidden footage that Jon
Ronson and Alex Jones got from Bohemian
Grove in like the [ __ ] late 90s I'm
gonna say how old is it like it was the
early 2000 cloudy shut the [ __ ] up you
can hear them they're lighting things on
fire that's the Molech the apples are
corncob there there's a monster what is
the with the volume on so you can hear
it put the blame you gotta listen to the
volume listen to this [ __ ]
so they have music under the lands dude
but give me give me the volume and
camping what do you think to our
documentary control document it's the
mob these simple as the intersections of
lights up crazy Regan there people have
been there forever they've been going
there since the beginning of time this
is one of those things where rich
powerful people get together and go hey
we're all in the same team
people like to be protected it's what
they do there is California in the
middle of the woods you got to go
through a guard checkpoint and I have I
have in this area of the second channel
in the safe there's this I have a friend
who's a producer who got in with one of
the biggest producers of all time for a
while I don't want to say any names but
he was in that crew that like this
there's this producer and he's got this
crew of all these different people and
his crew to produce [ __ ] he's it's like
a it's like a little gang right and it's
a top guy everybody knows this sure he
was involved and it was like a new
recruit yeah and they went to a city by
Bellini and Grove one road nobody no one
has access to unless you're part of this
group and it's a big-ass City he goes
it's like it's like you're in some
Middle East like Abu Dhabi Prince City
where everything is paved and just it's
insane California it's their city's
reach out to Joe so it's gonna reach out
like do you and shouldn't come in our
[ __ ] mess ain't no they can't control
China that's why he's not a big movie
star cuz they know they can't control
who doesn't want to be a movie here's
what I think I think that they're rich
they gave you 100 million you would know
if someone said I'm gonna give you a
hundred million a movie rider but but
here's what I think I think the rich and
powerful get together and have these
like they go to dinner they're gonna
retreat you know why I think they do it
a couple things you can't really okay
get the [ __ ] do drugs nobody's looking
that's where everything that's where FC
came in was they all thought they were
protected they altered this guy who has
these intelligence connections who's
a benefactor of science he loves and
money on science and he would donate
money to their causes and they're all
together and he was banging these girls
and so I'll bang them tisha and then go
to an island so they think they're
[ __ ] video tape media you're being
videotaped and you're also being used to
influence policy and influence I believe
yes I think I believe he going on I
believe he could very well have been an
entity of a Intelligence Agency like CIA
like the menorah
[Applause]